who's gonna be your favorite covergirl I
don't know if I should be on the cover I
don't know it's called old magazine not
G oh and G laughs together share a hug
and even dress alike in shades of gold
and beige Gayle couldn't believe it when
she was told by a staffer that she'd be
joining her bestie on the cover of oh I
said I'm on the cover did anybody check
with Oprah that's it
it was Oprah's idea what was that
photoshoot like with you I was it like
ogee Chronicles on ten on steroids the
cover is a big deal because up until now
lady O has done almost every single one
alone that's more than 230 shots this
issue is all about friendship and Oprah
and Gayle go back more than 40 years
people come up to me all the time and
introduce their friends to me as this is
my game so I think it means something
did you first met back in the 70s when
they work together at a Baltimore TV
station I think people were surprised
when they start first started seeing her
in CBS even like how did you learn TV
like so quickly she's been doing it
forever
Oprah also has a new passion project the
TV series David makes man she and
Michael B Jordan are executive producers
of the coming of age drama about a
teenage boy growing up in the projects
but now you're producing partner sir I
crazy
what is that life moment like oh it's
pretty cool
[Music]
[Applause]